[Musik]
mit spezielle atemtechnik die welt
verbessern
sie halten das für schwärmerei dann
hören sie mal was mein heutiger gast
dazu sagt herzlich willkommen zur
sternstunde religion ravi shankar ist
spiritueller lehrer friedensbotschafter
und glaubt volks einer der
einflussreichsten personen in den schön
dass sie hier sind schließlich sie sagen
ja dass spiritualität dann beginnen wenn
man sich selbst frage wer man ist wer
also sind sie
oder wie weit sind sie bei dieser frage
bereits gekommen
das ist die wesentliche frage die uns
hilft herauszufinden wie wir wirklich
sind und wenn wir realisieren dass wir
mehr sind als gedanken und emotionen
bewusstsein gibt uns das so viel kraft
dass wir unser lächeln nicht wegen
kleinen dingen verlieren und das haben
sie selber schon erreicht das denke ich
deshalb kann ich es anderen beibringen
sie nennt man ja in sri ravi shankar
aber schwierig ist so was wie eine ehren
bekundung wenn ich richtig informiert
bin gebührt ihnen also doppelte ehre
weil es shri shri heißt oder was meint
dass genau wann sie in indien tragen
viele diesen titel zwei fries bedeuten
hochwürden gewisse leute setzen 34 bis
zu 100 schließt wo ihre namen
ich fand zwei seien genug für mich es
gibt von niemandem verliehen dieser
ehren begründung sein gibt sich das
selber ja das tun die leute selber
ihr leben 2 schließt bedeuten würden
ja ihr leben liest sich auch sowie eine
typische biografie mit vier jahren seien
sie schon immer in meditation gefunden
worden
die lehrer kamen zu ihnen für ratschläge
sie haben schon die bagger twitter einer
der wichtigen im zentralen indischen
schriften rezitieren können haben yoga
gelernt sehr früh auf welche traditionen
beziehen sie sich dann ganz genau weil
eben der hinduismus es sehr groß
grundsätzlich ist der hinduismus eine
lebensart in der indischen philosophie
fühle ich mich wohl wie ein fisch im
wasser
es war daher sehr einfach für mich
obwohl ich wissenschaften studiert habe
lag mir die philosophie immer sehr am
herzen
ich teilte also ganz einfach mit anderen
was ich wusste und begann zu leeren
der zufall hat mich zum lehrer gemacht
eigentlich interessierte ich mich für
die wissenschaft ich finde ganz
interessant einer ihrer landsmänner und
literaturnobelpreisträgers rabindranath
tagore von ihm stammt der satz wer
durstig ist wird schon selbst zum fluss
finden oder zum schluss kommen
trifft das auch auf sie zu oder wie sind
sie dann können sie das mal nach
erzählen wie sie wirklich gut geworden
sind wie ich eben gesagt habe wollte ich
nicht lehrer werden
aber in meiner kindheit war ich von
vielen lehrern umgeben
mein erster lehrer hat 40 jahre lang mit
mahatma gandhi zusammengearbeitet so der
karikatur wedi brachte mahatma gandhi
die bawag gigabyte
ich bin also mit den geschichten großer
männer aufgewachsen mit magna gandhi
rabindranath tagore damals gab es eine
sehr feste werteordnung
dann begegnete ich vielen spirituellen
meistern
sie gaben ihren segen und beeinflussten
und wer war denn für sie der wichtigste
lehrer
sie haben jetzt mal hat man meine erste
lehrerin war meine mutter hat diese denn
gelernt
sie brachte mir viele dinge bei auch das
saiteninstrument wiener zu spielen
sie sind also auch ein musiker dazu weil
sie haben ja ein namensvetter ja aber er
war aus dem norden
ich bin aus dem süden und spiele ein
südländisches instrument das ähnlich ist
wie die sita und wiener genannt meine
mutter war auch gut in sanskrit erst
lehrte mich meine mutter dann zu der car
giotto wdr ist 118 jahre alt er lebt
immer noch
dann verbrachte ich zeit mit maritimer
er war auch schon in der schweiz bekannt
oder für die transzendentale meditation
und den seelisberg sind sie selber ich
glaube ich zwei jahre gewesen insgesamt
oder ja ich war ende der 1970 er jahre
dort um das vedische wissen weiter zu
geben dass sie studiert hatte damals
fand eine tagung statt bei dem es um die
verbindung zwischen dem vedischen wissen
und die wissenschaft ging also um
spiritualität und wissenschaft mich
interessierte beides deshalb haben wir
dort ein paar seminare für
wissenschaft haben sie denn betrieben
studiert wenn sie jetzt eigenes seien
ich studierte physik chemie und
mathematik
das volle programm ja ja und dann
maharishi yogi war der wird quasi der
dritte lehrer für sie wenn ich das
richtig verstehe und sie waren selber
lehrer damals in seelisberg natürlich
fragt man sich ich war kurze zeit dort
und diskutierte mit verschiedenen
wissenschaftlern aus der ganzen welt
ich glaube vorlesungen und studierte
vedische wissenschaft aber wann sind sie
dann selber zu diesen guru geworden der
sie heute sind sie sind sehr erfolgreich
sie haben über vier millionen anhänger
[Musik]
als ich wieder nach indien zurück ging
zog ich mich ende 1981 zehn tage zum
schweigen zur danach begann ich die
atemtechnik zu leeren
diese atemtechnik wurde so beliebt dass
viele menschen sie kennen lernen wollten
wir haben sie fast 350 millionen
menschen auf der ganzen welt beigebracht
würden sie denn sagen weil das fragt man
sich ja wenn sie ein guru sind dass sie
erleuchtet sind wenn sie sich des
zentrums ihres seins bewusst werden
haben sie das wichtigsten erfasst
das nennen wir erleuchtung mal steckt
dass in jedem menschen
man braucht ein reines herz klaren
verstand und ernsthaftes bemühen
das sind natürliche dinge die uns allen
eigen sind ob sie es erleuchtung totale
achtsamkeit oder klarheit der weisheiten
klar ist ihr wisst es bringt eine neue
dimension von totalem frieden und
harmonie in ihr leben
ich würde sagen es geht immer um das
gleiche
sie sind ja aus einer brach mahnen
familie das ist die oberste kaster sie
quasi auch mitunter die priesterkaste
und damit genießen sie ein intern schon
auch ein spezielles ansehen auf steht
zumindest ist es überhaupt denkbar dass
jemand ein guru in ihrem sinne aus einer
unteren kaste kommen würde
hier ist yahoos entstammen allen kasten
es ist das sieht man in der geschichte
indiens im zwölften jahrhundert gab es
viele heilige die aus allen kasten
stammten
auch wenn einer aus der untersten kaste
kommt wird er verehrt wenn er weise ist
warum geht es bei die erleuchtung
sie macht nicht halt vor kasten oder
regionen
sie macht keinen halt vor der untersten
kaste kann ja aber würden sie denn sagen
zumindest ihr kennt man viel weniger
weibliche gurus als männliche gurus
täuscht das oder ist das tatsächlich so
und wenn es so ist deshalb ist es so
denn es gibt keine weiblichen gurus hier
sind weniger bekannt man kennt ja und
dann hat sich schön und es gibt sie
gurus können männlich oder weiblich sein
und allen kasten entstammen es gibt
keine schranken jemand durch seine
erfahrung im bewusstseins training die
menschen helfen kann und über
bedingungslose liebe verfügt dann hat er
oder sie alles was einen guru ausmacht
diese person kann von überall her kommen
unabhängig von rasse oder geschlecht
es gibt absolut keine vorbehalte oder
schrank aber gibt es denn genau so viele
haben dass er nicht untersucht aber in
etwa genau so viele weibliche gurus wie
männliche kokos in indien
nicht gleich viele das stimmt was könnte
der grund dafür sein
noch freie plätze
sollte mir frauen geben
sie unterstützen das stark ich sehe das
schon wir haben auf der ganzen welt ja
sehr viele anhänger über fünf millionen
ich hab das schon gesagt aber trotzdem
das ist klar auch einige kritiker
mitunter wird eben kritisiert dass sie
spiritualität kommerzialisieren nicht
nur indem sie eben kurse anbieten
sondern indem sie auch wellness produkte
verkaufen
da habe ich mich gefragt ist das kein
widerspruch ein geschäftstüchtiger guru
zu sein
sehen sie das trifft auf jede
institution zu die viele bereiche
abdeckt bild aufzuhängen braucht man
einen rahmen gleichermaßen benötigt man
für die wissensvermittlung eine gewisse
organisationsstruktur
dazu gehört auch die finanzierung wir
tun das mit ayurveda unsere institution
unterrichtet junge begabte menschen in
ayurveda wir schaffen jobs für sie wir
betreiben eine universität und freie
schulen für 70.000 kinder dieses
karitative engagement ist nicht möglich
mit leerer kasse was ich anspreche hat
damit zu tun dass es in indien ja auch
heilige gibt die ganz abgelegen legen wo
einsiedler die an ganz anderen begriff
davon haben was es bedeutet wenn zb
heilig zu sein besitz losigkeit wird
groß geschrieben
und das meine ich wenn sie so viel
unterwegs sind wie sie sind wie können
sie dann überhaupt noch wirklich zur
ruhe kommen
es ist einfach friedvoll zu sein wenn
man nur dasitzt herausfordernde ist es
friedfertig zu sein während man
verantwortung für die ganze welt
übernimmt
und da beginnt die wahre herausforderung
einverstanden aber was machen sie denn
ganz genau jeden tag was ist ihre
tägliche routine um meine tägliche
routine besteht darin bei mir zu sein
meditation geschieht für mich während
des tages was immer ich tue tue ich für
die menschen auf der welt
ich möchte auf jedes gesicht ein lächeln
zaubern
ich frage mich immer wie ich noch
nützlicher sein kann für die
gesellschaft
jeden abend wird mich zudem eine gewisse
zeit die musik den sogenannten sahen wir
kommen zusammen und singen gemeinsam und
ich beantworte fragen es geht um die
weisheit die dinge aus einem anderen
blickwinkel zu betrachten
sie sagen die leute sind für sie sehr
wichtig und den leuten ein lächeln aufs
gesicht zu zaubern
ich habe bemerkt dass auf twitter haben
sie circa vier millionen oder mehr
fallen hingegen folgen niemanden weg
erklären sie sich diese asymmetrie woher
kommt die ihre frage ist ob ich jemandem
folge damit den anderen nicht gerecht
wem sollte ich folgen wenn ich jemandem
folge dann schenke ich dieser einen
person besondere aufmerksamkeit
entweder folge ich allen vier millionen
anhängern oder niemandem
ich habe entschieden niemandem zu folgen
in meiner position muss ich allen
gerecht werden egal ob sie reich arm
berühmt oder unbekannt sind
daran habe ich mich mein ganzes leben
gehalten
sie haben genau aus diesem grund auch
vor 40 jahren die art of living
foundation gegründet
und ich frage mich dazu ist das eine
religion ist es eine spirituelle
bewegung was ist das eigentlich genau
die foundations ziel der foundation ist
es den menschen zu vermitteln dass das
leben ein fest ist und alle menschen
glücklich zu machen
wir haben wir die alten techniken
modernisiert und allen menschen
zugänglich gemacht die alte technik
meinen sie die atemtechnik sudarshan
kriya genau weil im yoga ja diese arten
techniken insgesamt 1 also das hat man
immer schon gemacht dass ich nicht neu
ist ja aber gewisse dinge waren nicht
allen bekannt sodass ein krieger ist
eine tief greifende atemtechnik die
unsere emotionen reinigt dadurch fühlt
man sich innerlich frisch und kann
tiefer meditieren war früher tabu
es gab viele vorurteile als wir vor 40
jahren mit unseren kursen begannen
deshalb nenne ich meine organisation
kunst des lebens
vor 40 jahren hatte die allgemeinheit
keinen zugang zu yoga viele meinten wie
yoga praktizieren schwebel irgendwo da
oben
als wir mit unseren atem kursen begannen
sprachen die menschen darauf an es geht
um yoga und meditation aber nicht nur
wir vermitteln auch wie man das leben
aus einer weiteren perspektive
betrachten kann dies und meditation
hilft den menschen ihre emotionen besser
zu integrieren
aus depressionen herauszufinden innere
spannungen und familienkonflikte zu
überwinden
jetzt machen sie mit also einerseits ist
sehr interessant weil heute ist es ein
großer wandel selbst hier in europa ganz
viele leute machen yoga es gibt in jeder
stadt unzählige yoga strich aber
gleichzeitig was er zu erzählen das
klingt sehr interessanter machen sie
nicht neugierig können sie uns zeigen
wie diese methode geht wie atmet man
denn so wie man richtig atmet kann man
nicht einfach zeigen
es gibt verschiedene techniken nicht nur
eine wie macht man das
man sitzt bequem auf einem stuhl oder
auf dem boden und übt immer mit einem
lehre vorbereitet man sich mit der drei
stufen atmung vor also den mal hier und
dann tief vom unteren bauch über den
brustraum ist ganz hinauf
so lernt man rhythmisch zu atmen sagt
und das öffnet die tür zu einer tieferen
spirituellen erfahrung wie sind sie
darauf gekommen
auf diese technik ich habe mich einfach
zehn tagelangem schweigen geübt das war
endet 19 81 8
dann kam es wie musik wie ein gedicht zu
mir und ich begann es zu leeren
er ist klingt er tatsächlich nach einem
wunder heilmittel das ihnen quasi über
eine eingebung gegeben wurde würden sie
da zustimmen
ich würde nicht sagen dass es von
außerhalb kam sondern aus meinem
tiefsten inneren was sie was mich ein
bisschen stört an diesen erklärungen die
sie gegeben haben oder was ich auch
zuvor gelesen habe in den interviews ist
dass man eigentlich das leid so
problematisch zeigt man hat das gefühl
das schlechte im leben hat kann platz
aber das ist es doch genau was oft ein
leben ausmacht was eine persönlichkeit
ausmacht deswegen sollte sollten die
schlechten phasen nahezu ausgemerzt
werden
sehen sie das leiden ist unabwendbar
teil des leh
wir erleben freud und leid beides gehört
zum leben aber leiden ist freiwillig
geist kann sich an etwas festklammern
und ständig darauf herumkauen doch das
ist unnötig wie weise ist lässt die
vergangenheit los lernt von ihr aber
lebt im augenblick was passiert sonst
unser geist ist mit der vergangenheit
oder die zukunft beschäftigt wir ärgern
uns über die vergangenheit und ängstigen
uns vor der zukunft und das vergiftet
unseren körper es geht also darum die
vergangenheit zu vergessen vergangenes
zu vergeben und im augenblick zu leben
was macht denn genau eine schwer kranke
person wenn sie leidet was würden sie
empfehlen weil sie leidet er nicht
freiwillig sc diedersen einer ernsthaft
erkrankten person rate ich natürlich
einen arzt aufzusuchen und medikamente
zu nehmen
aber abgesehen davon würde ich ihr sagen
stärken sie ihren geist durch meditation
durch atemübungen sehen sie ein starker
geist kann einen schwachen körper tragen
aber ein schwacher geist kann nicht
einen starken körper tragen
das müssen wir begreifen wer einen
starken körper aber einen schwachen
geist hat der kommt nicht weiter mentale
innere kraft ist also sehr wichtig dann
sagen sie aber dann ist man selber
schuld wenn man leidet letztlich die
frage ob sie oder jemand anderer schuld
ist bringt nichts
darum geht es mir nicht
ich sage man solle seine innere kraft
suchen wenn man leidet geht es nicht
darum das leiden zu akzeptieren oder
sich darüber zu freuen
man muss darüber hinaus wachsen
eine dies das ist möglich hat das was
sie erklären auch mit dem ganzen kammer
prinzip zu tun dass man ja von hindu
religionen kennt und auch vom buddhismus
hinduismus und buddhismus sprechen über
karma damit sind prägungen des
bewusstseins gemeint und es gibt einen
weg sich von karma zu befreien
meditation ist der weg um unser leid zu
überwinden - vom schmerz zu befreien
es ist sogar wissenschaftlich erwiesen
dass sich das atmen und die meditation
auf den schmerz auswirken
ich denke die welt verändert sich die
menschen anerkennen unsere arbeit als
wir vor 40 jahren über meditatives atmen
sprachen reagierten die leute ziemlich
ab während das aber heute sehen sie wie
viel ihnen das bringt die nutzen ist
enorm
damit bringen sie mich gleich zum
nächsten punkt es hat ja auch einen
großen einfluss auf reede sagen sie sie
haben an verschiedenen orten schon
friedensverhandlungen durchgeführt eben
auf der basis ihrer atemtechnik auf der
basis von meditation in kolumbien glaube
ich ist zuletzt 2015 ein sehr großer akt
geschehen wo sie da die väter mit der
regierung versöhnen konnte es wurde ein
friedensvertrag ausgehandelt können sie
uns etwas darüber erzählen wie kann man
mit atmen die welt verändern ist nur ein
aspekt
es geht um energie wenn sie eine
positive energie ausstrahlen hören die
menschen auf sie und wer ihnen zuhört
wird davon erfasst
ich würde sagen es braucht positive
energie
denn in dem text werde sincere und
ernsthaftes bemühen mit liebe und
menschlichkeit ist alles möglich ist
genau das ist passiert aber das haben ja
vielleicht andere leute genauso schon
versucht was ist so speziell an ihrem
ansatz deswegen sind sie so erfolgreich
damit
das werk das fragen mich alle
ich habe keine ahnung aber was machen
sie genau mit den leuten diskutieren sie
uns das mal nichts weil sie sitzen ja
nicht einfach da und dann und dann ist
der friede
was machen sie in den ersten tagen
unsere begegnung waren sie ablehnen
sie wollten mich nicht treffen deswegen
begab ich mich nach kuba am ersten tag
war die führung ablehnend dann kamen sie
zu einem öffentlichen vortrag an der
universität und schließlich trafen sie
sich mit mir und wir sprachen drei tage
lang miteinander
am letzten tag nahmen sie mit mir an
einer pressekonferenz teil und erklärten
sich mit einem einseitigen
waffenstillstand einverstanden
ich weiß dass in jeder person ein
wunderbares wesen steckt jeder trägt
einen schmerz sich jeder täter ist auch
opfer wenn wir diesen schmerz heilen
verschwindet das böse im theater das ist
es was passiert
viele milizen in indien gaben ihre
waffen ab und fanden zur normalität
zurück
gewaltlosigkeit ist das ziel wenn wir
den inneren kern eines menschen berühren
verändert er sich
sie sprechen dieses diesem verletzten
teilen menschen an sagen sie das ist
quasi das rezept wie sie die leute
zusammenbringen können haben sie auch
schon misserfolge gehabt ich habe
gelesen denn es haben sie auch eine
quasi eine einladung geschickt und die
haben nicht aber wir haben in
gefängnissen auf der ganzen welt gelehrt
und gegen 800 1000 gefangenen erreicht
das ist ein klarer beweis dafür dass
intern die zu gefängnisstrafen
verurteilt worden sind ein menschlicher
kern eine gute person steckt wenn wir
diese essenz berühren kommt sie zum
vorschein
auch in sri lanka habe ich versucht die
anführer der tamil tigers zur vernunft
zu bringen
es hat nicht funktioniert
sie glaubten mehr an die militärische
macht als an eine friedliche lösung
und leider kam es zum krieg das ist sehr
traurig aber ich habe mich dort um eine
friedliche lösung bemüht
bei ihnen man hört dass jetzt auch schon
raus vermischt sich aber doch religion
mit politik oder also sie sind bei
friedensverhandlungen dabei sie sprechen
auf die welt friedenskonferenzen und man
sieht sie schulter an schulter mit dem
premierminister narendra modi auf bühnen
was hat es damit auf sich
das werde auch kritisiert anlässlich von
großen konferenzen sind alle willkommen
in einer demokratie gibt es nicht nur
eine partei leute aus allen parteien
nehmen daran teil einer welle
staatsoberhaupt oder der premierminister
sein programm vorstellt sind viele leute
aus der ganzen welt zu gehen
dreieinhalb millionen menschen
verfolgten unsere veranstaltung in delhi
unsere programme haben nichts mit
politikern und für sich zu tun
wir gaben meditationskurse im
europäischen parlament und auf dem
capitol hill in den usa und erreichten
damit viele senatoren die demokratie hat
vier pfeiler die judikative legislative
und exekutive und die medien wenn alle
zusammenarbeiten können handfeste
resultate erreicht werden
mir geht es in der frage fallen auch
darum dass eben die politik von modi
auch insofern kritisierte dass der
minderheits religionen in indien das
heißt die muslime die christen speziell
unterdrückt werden jetzt mit der
wiederwahl ist es noch mehr aufgewacht
und wenn da jemand wie sie der so große
anhängerschaft hat sich neben modi
stellt und ihn damit unterstützt macht
auch ein signal unterstütze niemanden
auch nicht bei den wahlen im auftrag des
hohen gerichtshofs von indien vermittle
ich im konflikt zwischen den hindus und
den muslimen der seit vierhundert oder
fünfhundert jahren andauert auch in
dieser position kann ich nicht über
politik sprechen
ich weiß wo man platz ist ich bleibe sie
neutral und alle kommen zu mir einen
fehler macht spreche ich es an
egal wie es ist ich fürchte niemanden
wenn jemand innerhalb oder außerhalb die
regierung etwas falsches tut erhebe ich
meine stimme kritisiere sein verhalten
und sage was richtig ist wir sind leider
schon am ende des gesprächs angekommen
wir könnten noch lange miteinander
weiteren ich habe eine letzte frage an
sie nämlich mit allem was sie jetzt
schon wissen haben sie eigentlich noch
irgendwelche fragen an das leben oder
ist für sie schon alles klar
wenn ich fragen hätte würde ich nicht
hier sitzen
vielen herzlichen dank trägt spricht ich
denke so much jetzt geht es direkt
weiter mit indien und zwar dem süden des
landes dort steht nämlich eine der
größten religiösen stätten des
kontinents zweites ziel der geliebten
chivas minaj ii einen schönen sonntag
und bis bald
[Musik]